hey BB Hi how are you looking cute where
are you going girl
looking cute for you girl okay well I'm
looking cute for you let's talk about
this song it is an Anthem inspired by
love and relationship so I want to know
what can you tell us about that because
I want to be in your business
well you know I feel like one thing we
do sometimes is not follow our hearts
and
lie all we want like our hearts can't
lie so the song is about being in a
relationship and then just kind of
falling out of love and but being
Unapologetic about it because a lot of
times judge ourselves when it comes to
love and a change of heart and I think
that's part of
life you know what I mean yeah what does
bibi's heart want
bibi's heart hmm
um
a lot of things
you have to be more specific what does
bibi's heart want when it comes to love
and relationships and the future
uh I'm all about
um well when it comes to love I mean
damn there's so many layers to that you
know
I feel like if you're talking about a
relationship
um I think it comes like maybe what
baby's heart wants is honesty Trust
happiness I think those are all
important things for me yeah you would
date someone in the industry right
never never
know from you and I never have wow BB
that's something wrong
but girl the
um there have have been guys though in
the industry that have tried oh of
course look at you girl you crazy The
Block is Hot no but it's like oh gosh
girl it's like
not easy yeah no I tried going on a date
in the past like you know and I was just
like this is not gonna happen this is
not gonna work for me it's a different
beast that's for sure it's just too much
well let's talk about the video okay
because the video is giving Barbie core
meets Madonna hung up okay but what was
the ultimate inspiration for you
well I've been working on this project
for about a year now my
I'll have to take all the things that I
love from the 70s because growing up I
grew up in an Albanian household and you
know that's what my parents played you
know and if they played American Music
it was like maybe dance and my mom loved
hip-hop
but we never like I never grew up on 70s
music so I did a deep dive and fell in
love with Fleetwood Mac fell in love
with Disco
and I just wanted to incorporate that in
the whole era sonically and Visually so
let's go back to the video because it
looked like a wild party you look
stunning in it I know it was filmed in
Spain how hot was it like were you dying
behind the scenes
the funny story about the music video
for I'm good is we shot
the video on a boat in Ibiza yeah and it
was so windy that the boat was rocking
so much that everybody on that boat I
have and I took pictures because I I
took video because I was like this
nobody's gonna ever believe me everybody
on that boat was like throwing up it was
no
it was so bumpy we were literally
holding on I was like I'm good yeah
but in the video you could never you'll
never tell like you'll never tell yeah I
felt so bad everybody was so sick it was
so everybody's getting that you know
motion sickness it was great yeah did
you get motion sickness or were you like
for a good second for a good second when
I was um we were filming we took a
little break
um and because everybody was not feeling
well even the director wasn't feeling
well and I was like this is not going as
planned and then I started getting sick
for a second and then I was like but I
knew that if I threw up that it would I
think it just kind of makes it you get
makes you it worse like yeah like when
you throw up like it's not over for the
end of the day but if you could hold it
back you know so I was like I cannot
throw up I cannot grow up so we did the
video and it was yeah it was crazy God
bless you God bless you
um let's talk about you sliding in Snoop
Dogg's DMS let's just get to it okay
because that's what I want to know
oh gosh so yeah I had this song I you
know on my new album
and I was like oh man I would love Snoop
Dogg on this yeah and I was like you
know what let me just Instagram him like
may I send him a message on Instagram I
was like what like how does it hurt like
you know what I mean how could it hurt
and um I was like Hey Snoop um I have
this song called satellite and I think
it would be really awesome if you were
on it I'd love to send it to you and if
you like it great if not like that's
totally fine yeah and he literally
FaceTime me the next morning at 7 00 a.m
oh my God being like check your inbox
and I was like
yeah check my email it was his um he oh
sorry that's my dog sorry no it's so
cute
sorry she's a
she's a feisty one
um when I checked my when I checked my
uh inbox it was the song with Snoop on
it oh my God
facetimed you at 7am
sorry oh yes
oh you're so cute with your ears oh my
God stop
sorry she's a little she's a little bad
you know she's my bad girl she's cute
she's really cute oh my god
um wait he facetimed you at 7am were you
like ready to answer a FaceTime at that
time no way I was like I was like my
hair was a mess I had just woken I
looked and I'm like okay well I have to
pick this up Snoop Dogg like I can't
knock it up so I was like hey what's up
yeah you have another collab with Dolly
Parton the icon
was that a pinch me moment for you
I mean Dolly Parton is an icon
um she's not only one of my favorite
artists but one of my favorite
songwriters she wrote I Will Always Love
You Yeah Houston and she has her version
as well so I always looked up to Dolly
Parton I'm like wow not only is she a
bad
period
like she looks good she can sing like
crazy but she's writing all these
incredible records and she is also like
she's also a boss like she has you know
Dolly is it Dollywood
oh I think so yes yes Nollywood she's a
produce she was a producer on The
Vampire Diaries or something like that
like she's done a lot of stuff like
she's a boss
you know like I just feel like
this I just even to this moment the fact
that I have a song with dolly is just
like I can't grasp it and every time I
listen to it like the perverse part just
because she talks you know it's called
seasons and it's about change and it's
really cool to get her perspective on
the song and my perspective like two
different Generations but we're still
women and we're all we're still learning
and we're growing and we're changing and
just having a song with Dolly like
I could have no other feature on my
album except her and I would be happy
but I'm very grateful for the others but
I'm just saying like
she that was it's a dream come true